نحن في خرصا يعود بعض الاوكرانيين الى
بيروزيركا ويوفقون وصولهم بنزع ملصقه
روسيه من اللوحات الاعلانيه كتب عليها
روسيا هنا الى الابد
كيف بالانسحاب الروسي وتصيفه بانه النصر
مهم تؤكد المخابرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
ان خرسا بات تحت السيطره وان الوحدات
العسكريه دخلت المدينه تكتب اوكرانيا نصرا
مهما اخر في الوقت الحالي وتثبت انه رغم
اقوال وافعال روسيا ستنتصر اوكرانيا
لقواتها من مدينه خيرسون الاستراتيجيه
بسعاده عشرات المناطق التي تتناثر بها
الالغام في الجنوب اثرا انسحاب الروسي
منها واعاده تمركزهم في الجانب الايسر من
نهر النيترو
عند الساعه الخامسه صباحا وبالتجاه خرسون
تم الانتهاء من نقل قواتنا الى الضفه
اليسرى لنهر جني برو يعتبر الكرملين ان
منطقه خرصنه الاوكرانيه باكملها تشكل جزءا
من روسيا رغم انسحابها من المنطقه التي
احتلتها شهر سبتمبر الماضي
انهار جسر انتونيفرسكي عند الطريق الوحيد
القريب من مدخل مدينه خرسا الى الضفه
الشرقيه التي تسيطر عليها روسيا عند نهر
النيبرو حيث لم يتضح بعد سبب انهيار الجسر